is 108 megapixels really that much
better than 48 well that's what I
thought at least in terms of detail but
I went out and I took a ton of photos
both compressed files raw files and
expert raw and the results were kind of
crazy let's Jump Right In Here with
standard compressed photos the Samsung
has more contrast and saturation it
might look a little bit more detailed
but when we punch in the iPhone actually
looks a little bit more detailed the
Samsung looks a little bit over
processed in the trees there where the
iPhone looks more natural and by the way
these photos have not been edited at all
I'll let you know when we get to that
portion and this shot obviously we have
some white balance differences but
focusing on the detail it's hard to tell
but when we look closer you don't see
more detail in the Samsung even though
it has more than twice the resolution by
the way I made sure both of these are
updated to the latest software for this
comparison in this photo I'm surprised
the iPhone has more contrast on the
Samsung Samsung's more saturated taking
a closer look my son does look more
detailed on the Samsung whereas the
iPhone has more detail with those shrubs
we have a lot more going on with this
image the first thing that pops out to
me is the sky the Samsung it looks like
some of it's clipping so dynamic range
isn't as good and yes it's a lot harder
to do HDR on 108 megapixels compared to
48 and the iPhone has that a16 and when
we look closer we have more noise on the
Samsung and that car looks a lot more
flat and then that shrub right there
crazy amount of detail on the iPhone now
another thing I noticed is that with the
Samsung in 108 megapixel mode you just
don't have the HDR and even some of the
lens Distortion that goes away in 12
megapixel you don't have so the iPhone
looks a lot better once again I have not
edited these and if anything else sticks
out to you comment down below now this
is a very difficult image we have that
grass that's popping from the Sun all
those shadows and when I look closer I
was shocked to see all the artifacts on
the Samsung compared to the iPhone
retaining all that detail I had to
research this and I'll explain why this
is happening later in the video I wanted
to take a shot without difficult
lighting so here's one in our studio
both of these are unprocessed I just
converted the raw to a JPEG and when we
take a look closer it is absolutely
insane the difference in detail the
iPhone is tack sharp now in this image I
could tell that the iPhone has more
detail with that better dynamic range
looking closer the over saturation of
those leaves there makes it look like
it's kind of blending together whereas
the iPhone looks realistic almost like
it's from a DSLR and I'm not trying to
sabotage the Samsung I just think it's
too much processing with 108 megapixels
to make this all happen and fast enough
which is why I also tested out raw but
first check out these cases from our
sponsor M Kiki who have been making
affordable cases since 2015 with over a
hundred thousand positive reviews they
have clear cases for the whole iPhone 14
lineup and not only do they have
standard but these cool gradient
versions that get darker on the sides
towards the bottom they are slim while
having 6D protection with upgraded
airbag bumpers for military grade shock
protection as well as a 1.9 millimeter
raised lip to protect your screen and a
three and a half millimeter raised bezel
on the back to protect your cameras
while being aware and scratch resistant
anti-yellowing and comfortable in the
hand check them out and get an
additional 15 off mkiki's already super
low prices on either the fully clear
gradient or their other color cases by
using the special links in the video
description below here is a raw shot
look how much more natural the tree
trees look now now of course it's not
processed so you see the dynamic range
and in this one both are Samsung shots
but I pushed the rod just a bit and even
though it's saturated we don't have all
the highlights in the tree kind of
mushing together and this is the last
jpeg comparison it's a very tough shot
with bright highlights in the background
and shadows and punching in this is just
crazy now obviously you see the
difference in dynamic range the trees at
the top are blown out as are the Rocks
but what's interesting to me is that the
rocks are all warmer but then in the
shade it is cooler and now it is time to
get into the raw shot starting out with
their Pro application now right at the
gate I found that the Samsung
overexposes the image if you're using
Auto exposure so I switched to manual
and I tried to find the best balance of
exposure after that I went into
Lightroom and I started playing with the
image to get the most of it while
keeping it looking natural and here is
the difference from the raw shot as you
guys could see it looks a lot better and
more natural the iPhone by the way is
still unprocessed and taking a closer
look here the tree at the top looks much
more natural compared to the previous
shot where it was all crunchy and
Overexposed here's a direct comparison
between the Samsung rot and the jpeg
looks much more natural but the iPhone
still looks better in terms of detail
and dynamic range so with that said
let's go ahead and compare the dynamic
range with the raw from both of these
here's the first shot and you can see
that the Samsung's single raw file
exposed to the Shadows blows out the sky
I went ahead and I adjusted that as much
as I could and while the Shadows look
great I could not pull back all the
highlights from the sky and here we have
a very tough situation so this is just
neutrally exposed you see the highlights
are blown out the shot Shadows are too
dark so I took a shot exposing for the
Shadows I want to see how much I can
pull back in the highlights and editing
it I could not pull back that sky or the
street so I decided to expose for the
highlights the sky there and once I did
my best editing it this is what I got
now the highlights they don't pop as
much as on the iPhone shot that is
unedited and the Shadows they don't look
too bad but punching in we have a lot of
artifacting and noise because we had to
push up the Shadows too much so how in
the world do the iPhone's raw shots look
so good even though I didn't touch them
well when Apple announced Pro raw they
said that this is the first format that
can still make use of stacking multiple
images using their deep Fusion
technology and that makes for a really
good looking image even though it's raw
while at the same time not baking in
things like sharpening white balance
tone mapping you know highlights and all
all those things you can still adjust
that makes for a much better looking
image with great dynamic range compared
to a single raw file now about a year or
a little bit more than that after Apple
announced Pro raw Samsung announced
their expert raw app that also does a
very similar thing now this app is not
pre-loaded on the phone it's not even
the Play Store you have to download it
from the Samsung store and I took a
variety of shots to see how good the
Samsung can do now as you guys could see
the expert raw shot still doesn't look
as good as apples if you don't edit
either one of them so I went into
Lightroom and I want to see how much of
that sky can get out but there wasn't
that much information there so then I
went ahead and started making
adjustments I selected the sky
separately and this is the final result
trying to get as much as I could out of
that image now the Samsung's does look a
little over processed I was just trying
to get the same dynamic range and
punching in here even though the Samsung
is stacking photos we still have a lot
of noise artifacting now this shot looks
crazy but the sunset was beautiful and
gorgeous full of colors and my wife was
facing away from it I did a detailed job
editing the sky and Alina separately and
this is how far I was able to push that
image there's just not a lot of
highlight recovery that you can do
almost like it's not really a raw file
kind of like a higher bit rate jpeg
because of that I underexposed on the
Samsung and my wife was in a darker spot
and then I brought all that up I
adjusted her separately from the sky I
really try to get as much dynamic range
out of sky as I could and the sky does
look good and she is nice and bright now
but it did push it a bit too far because
if you guys look at the top left corner
we have so much noise and stuff that was
crashed same thing with the tree in the
background it just doesn't look the same
now the iPhone shots I still have not
touched so this time around I actually
did push the iPhone shots more I was
able to recover more highlights from
this Sky push your exposure up as well
and here is a close-up of Alina now the
Samsung looks sharper because the whole
image is filled with artifacts where on
the left hand side looks like the iPhone
wasn't really shooting 48 megapixels
because it was really dark it chose to
bend the image now I told you guys about
this in my previous video that even if
you're shooting Pro raw if it gets dark
the iPhone will do a 12 megapixel shot
and I don't know if you guys have
noticed it yet but the Samsung if you're
shooting raw even expert raw it does not
record 108 megapixels they are all
banned down so you don't get that super
high resolution because of that even an
easy lighting and if you edit the images
to look their best the Samsung still
cannot compete in terms of detail when
looking into this I found a lot of
people that complained about this online
that they want the natural colors be
able to process it but they also want
the high resolution which you can't get
unless you shoot the compressed file
files which don't have that natural look
and now let's take a look at dark and
night shots and it gets even worse if
you're taking 108 megapixel you do not
get that night mode that looks so great
whereas the iPhone's Pro Rock can still
do that now I didn't know this at first
and I was taking images here and it was
taking longer exposures but as you can
see it is so dark on the Samsung and
switching to 108 megapixel jpegs well it
seems like it's doing night mode but the
image still looks terrible because it's
focusing the processing on all of those
megapixels dropping down to plain old 12
megapixel compressed files well here is
a shot with the night mode it definitely
is a lot brighter looks good but then in
the sky we have all those artifacts and
we're not bringing out the stars because
it also does not allow you to do a very
long exposure like the iPhone does or a
pixel now in the super dark scene the
night mode with Pro Rob brought no up
whereas the 108 megapixel jpeg mode it
just was too dark switching to Raw it
looks better I want to see how much I
can push and pull these images to make
it look more like the iPhones but
unfortunately it falls apart there's a
lot of artifacting in the face and a lot
of that is just crushed detail there so
I turned on some more lights and the
expert raw it just does not look good
there's weird colors weird artifacting
whereas Apple's Pro raw looks great I
switched it to plain old regular 12
megapixel shots that are compressed and
it looks a lot better now so I'll say if
it's really dark just use the standard
mode and if it's not too dark shoot the
108 megapixel so you get that detail now
here it looks pretty good and punching
in the iPhone's 48 megapixel still beats
out the 108 megapixels in terms of
detail as well as dynamic range if you
look at the lights in the bottom right
hand side and with that a for shooting
the compressed mode so that doesn't take
forever you have all the features like
night mode and things like that well
when we bring up both of these images I
edited the pro raw uh you can bring them
up but you have a lot of artifacting and
all the shadows for example the top
right and left of the images and then of
course in your subject as well and you
have worse dynamic range so it's kind of
like you get everything with the iPhone
you have all the features of the pro raw
uh the images look great even if you
don't touch them and edit them but the
Samsung you have to choose do you want
to compress image that's crunchy and the
dynamic range isn't good uh and the
colors are kind of mushed together or do
you want to have more flexibility but
lower resolution and you don't have
night mode takes longer to shoot it's
just kind of crazy so why in the world
is 108 megapixels a lot worse than 48
well as I mentioned 48 is a lot easier
to process but with that the sensor that
is in here hasn't really changed much
back from when Samsung first entered
reduced it now the first version sucked
with autofocus and we covered that but
then the updated version they fixed
autofocus but since then the actual
performance and the readout of the
sensor hasn't really changed so this is
a really old sensor in here that they
keep reusing and that's why when they're
using their jpegs they can do more
processing to it it doesn't look too bad
still not great but the actual raw
performance even with expert raw they
cannot just make up for the fact that
it's an old sensor it's a lot more
dotted process with a weaker processor
compared to a sensor that just came out
on the iPhone it's new it's efficient
and the a16 is very good you guys have
mail down the comments section uh what
your thoughts are and if you guys
appreciate all the crazy effort that
went to this video took a long time
please hit that subscribe button above
check out one of those videos right over
there that's been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]
foreign